[Musique]
boit son thé huile jujubes chocolat tous
ces produits vendus légalement au canada
contiennent du cbd une des molécules
présentes dans le cannabis
et le cbd a bonne presse on lui accorde
des vertus relaxantes
on dit aussi que les cbd pourrait
favoriser le sommeil et même venir à
bout de douleurs chroniques
mais est-ce trop beau pour être vrai
direction st-cyrille-de-wendover à la
feuille verte spécialisée dans la
production de cbd
le cannabis mais santé acheter donc il
ya la fameuse molécule de cbd canal
idéal qu on en a beaucoup parlé depuis
la dernière décennie non nous c'est sur
cette molécule de l'issic on travaille à
la feuille verte
on visite les immenses installations
avec dany lefebvre fondateur de
l'entreprise attia brut que ça ne
règlera abriter les milliers de salles à
roddick étant donné que les gens
consomment de cbd le confort
les fans via net est soi même des fins
thérapeutiques pour aider à l'anxiété
parfois on entend parler pour aider au
sommeil
à la feuille verte on cultive plusieurs
variétés du cannabis qui produisent peu
ou pas de thc la molécule présente mais
beaucoup de ces bd celle dite relaxant
comme entrepreneur il a confiance aux
différentes recherches qui se font
actuellement sur le potentiel
thérapeutique du cbd on a trois produits
en un an avant dont les fameuses
capsules dont nos capsules comporte 25
mg de cbd par unité est également on a
un produit qu'on va appeler ça le cbd
active et donc c'est un cb dessécher et
mise en pots et les gens peuvent venir a
ajouté ça alors salaires dans leur
smoothie et faire en sorte de venir
ajouté vraiment le les bienfaits du cbd
à travers leur nourriture leur régime au
québec il n'y a qu'elle est excusé c'est
qu'on puisse acheter les produits dits
récréatif avec cbd
résultat des courses
terme en 2000
[Musique]
le docteur didier jutras a soit des
chercheurs au chum il a aussi collaboré
avec le ministère de la santé pour
établir le plan de formation des
conseillers de la escudé
certains secteurs dans la pratique
médicale
des effets les cantons pour lequel on a
le plus de données leur actuellement
c'est beaucoup l'épilepsie et tout ça
encore beaucoup le garder en tête dans
des conditions les canadiens l'état
ministre à des dosages extrêmement
beaucoup plus élevé que finalement ce
qui se retrouve notamment sur le marché
légal actuel noté la pétition dans les
dosages disponibles actuellement escudé
est ce qu'on peut espérer quelque chose
évidemment si vous consommez des très
petites doses de cbd est possible que
vous ayez pas d'effet du tout
une opinion partagée par le ministère de
la santé et des services sociaux du
québec il n'est pas possible
actuellement de déterminer avec
certitude que le cbd présente des effets
bénéfiques ou thérapeutiques lors de la
consommation de produits de cannabis
disponible à la escudé c est ce que ça
veut dire pas d'effets non pas du tout
ce que ça veut dire c'est qu'on n'a pas
de données pour l'heure pour le soutenir
on se dirige maintenant à magog à la
clinique nature medic rencontrer la
docteure andreea bosneag
ce soir qu'il ya cinq six ans on aimait
beaucoup ses bd et war
c'est le médicament le traitement
magique qui a pas d'effets secondaires
ça marche ça marche pour tous donc c'est
ça qu'elle on a commencé à l'utiliser
j'appelle à toutes les sauces qui est
super parce que fameux permis en fait de
faire des échecs pour pouvoir constater
finalement que le cb dit fonctionne pas
dans telle propriété
pour docteur bosniaques à l'utilisation
d'un sim et des supervisé par un médecin
peut avoir des effets positifs
donc mon avis le cbd sur l'anxiété oui
il ya des belles propriétés sur
l'anxiété sommeil
oui oui c'est certain passé faut les
choisir douleurs musculaires oui le cbd
par exemple qu'il fasse son effet
analgésique entière flammes at war pour
qu'il soit pris vraiment de façon
régulière au moins deux fois par jour au
médical on peut aller chercher des
concentrations à 2,50 chf 1 milligramme
par millilitre mais ça prend vraiment un
accord dharma professionnel quelqu'un
qui a l'habitude de consulter docteur
google qui voit que c'est 30 milliards
et airbus a320 sans fil et dix capsules
le souvent les effets secondaires sont
reconnus l'huile de cbd par exemple
c'est leur fioul a dit allez met
directement relié à la quantité d'huile
en fait le cbd dont vous parlez ce qu'il
est acheté lsq déçu on devrait pas aller
à la scu décès mais vraiment aller voir
un professionnel de la santé qui
pourrait à mieux nous guider dans nos
choix et aussi fogar dans ta caisse que
dc c'est pas des professions de la santé
ceux des vendeurs donc même un lion le
mont-dore de santé canada qui n'ont même
pas le droit de se prononcer sur les
plus impatients question si ses côtés
sont ils
pas droit
j'ai contacté trois succursales dans
trois villes différentes en faisant
passer pour un consommateur j'ai des
amis qui prennent des boissons à base
d'eaux
ça fait pas
[Musique]
nous avons bien sûr prévenu les scuds et
c'est que certains de leurs prix avait
le conseil est facile
la escudé ci se dit surprise et
préoccupée par les réponses obtenues
mais se dit confiante que la majorité de
leurs mille conseillers respecte la
proche conseil a prises dans leur
formation
la scuderia rappelait ses employés de ne
pas offrir d'avis de nature médicale et
de référé les clients à leurs
spécialistes de la santé
parce que les produits à faible teneur
en cbd ne représente pas ou peu de
danger santé canada étudie la
possibilité de retirer ces produits des
boutiques autorisé comme la spdc pour
les mettre en vente libre d'ailleurs
dans certains états américains on peut
en acheter dans des grandes chaînes
comme les pharmacies walgreen
richy mariani a dirigé une étude sur la
consommation de cbd au canada we found
[Musique]
contrairement aux produits avec thc ce
avec ses bd attire une clientèle plus
âgée même que le quart des utilisateurs
sont des personnes retraitées
indiqué démographique soit
[Musique]
visiblement le marché des produits aussi
bd est en plein ça il ya beaucoup
d'argent en jeu un potentiel de 2
milliards de dollars juste canada alors
gardons la tête froide car en plus de
coûter cher pour beaucoup de produits il
ne s'agit peut-être que de la poudre aux
yeux